c'est la journée des casse tête
salut je reviens de tourner je me suis
donc levé à 4h30 du matin pour venir
faire un casse tête on devait faire ce
casse tête ce soir enfin en fin de
journée et le x tu m'as dit
parce que
c'est incroyable du coup je me retrouve
avec une carence extrême de sommeil à
faire un casse tête qui si ça se trouve
est très facile et 6,3 me prendre 17
heures et si ça se trouve on ne sait pas
c'est la smiley box créé par constantin
est ce que ce mec fabrique des
casse-têtes huit par jour il en invente
il c'est pas possible et à chaque fois
ils sont très cool je vous mets de bien
de se tester dans la description comme
d'habitude vous remettra un lien plutôt
vers l'insoluble qui la boutique que
j'aime bien qui vend des casse tête et
où je les prends et loïc au j'aimerais à
générique qui pèse non qui m'anime non
un peu des deux
[Musique]
assassins des baisses des 700 lits des
petits indices et roundup c'est
l'assassin des pissenlits j'avoue que
j'ai pas bien compris ce casse tête est
ce que c'est une boîte à ouvrir ce que
c'est quand même la forme d'une boîte et
puis là ça bouge un peu on va d'explorer
ensemble ou est ce qu'il faut faire
sortir la pièce d'ici ou est ce que il
faut mettre les petites dents kiala la
dent dans la pièce en plastique dans des
espèces de montagne qui alla sais pas je
sais pas trop dans quoi on s'engage et
c'est cool c'est ce que j'avais dans les
boîtes caisse mais de manière générale
donc génial on va sur sa petite fun fact
avant de commencer une intelligence
artificielle créée par les chercheurs de
l'université d'irvine aux états unis a
réussi à résoudre un rubik's cube en
moins de 1,2 seconde pression' ans quand
même et je sais pas combien de temps une
intelligence artificielle pour remettre
pour résoudre un casse tête comme la
smiley boxe mais si le sujet vous
intéresse sachez que la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui sponsorisé par l'institut
montaigne une association qui produit
des idées politiques publiques avec la
fondation abbé ona et le leader de la
formation en ligne open classroom il
vous offre une opportunité de vous
former gratuitement à l'intelligence
artificielle se déplacer écouter de la
musique faire des achats en ligne
l'intelligence artificielle aller
partout mais qui serait ici de
m'expliquer concrètement comment elle
fonctionne on en reparle dans quelques
minutes avec les sponsors des
vidéocassettes c'est très important
parce que vous souvenez de la grosse
boîte à 15000 euros d du casse tête à
quelques milles et celui à 3000 bon ben
là il y en a un en préparation et en
commande qui est encore plus énorme que
tout ce que je peux dire que je me
verrais ça bientôt j'ai hâte de le faire
lui aussi à un trombone alors smagghe
les boks donc je vous disais tout à
l'heure je sais pas trop ce qu'il faut
en faire ce que j'ai vu juste en prenant
dans mes mains c'est que la base était
un peu amovible j'arrive à la tournée
comme ça
je vois qu'il ya deux petites vis ici 2e
trou et deux petits points là du côté du
haut ça m'a l'air vraiment ou fixe je
pense que ça c'est des vrais vis mais
que le jeu quand même c'est de retirer
comme ça parce qu'on ne sait jamais
créateur de castets son sont taquins de
ces deux trucs là qu'ils se lèvent un
peu
espace davis mais j'ai pas l'impression
tout va bien falloir qu'il se passe
quelque chose à un moment donné en tout
cas les rondelles en métal aussi elle
bouge sur ces axes la via sept bouts de
plastique là donc qui est vidé par trois
endroits et je me dise qu'il rudoie
rentrer quelque part ou pas qui doit
sortir je sais pas trop que j'arrive pas
à anticiper il faut est ce que c'est
parce que ça il faut l'ouvrir à la fin
et dans ces cas à à à temps parce que
salah cette pièce là les deux pico si ça
se trouve ça peut rentrer après ici et
donc appuyé sur celle de truquer nous
libérer quelque chose c'est possible que
ce soit ça ok j'étais en train de me
demander si ça ça se dévisser ou si ça
simplement si j'arrivais en fait en gros
ces trois éléments là ils peuvent tomber
ou pas et je me dis si j'arrive à les
bloquer si j'arrive en fait à dissocier
le bout de plastique de ces deux bouts
de métal peut-être il peut glisser en
fait qu'est ce que je veux dire est-ce
que ça avec les petites dents je
pourrais pas quand même le mettre un peu
dans les petites dents je me dis si
j'arrive à le mettre dans le petit
d'enjeux peut le bloquer et peut-être
levé que chez pas petit un bail comme ça
moi je vais c'est encore dévissé parce
que parce qu'on ne sait jamais je pense
qu'il ya un bail comme ça entre les deux
sus de hp c'est de faire que d'un côté
c'est à dire de faire passer le bout de
plastique
dessus ou dessous le bout de métal qui à
la lie des îles est un tout petit peu
sur celui ci on va bien j'ai pas j'ai
pas assez d'espacé pour aller plus loin
par contre j'ai réussi à le tourner en
faisant celle donc c'est pas non non non
ça vous
les retourner dans le sens nancy serait
comme ça d'acord comme ça ça passe alors
là là ça m'a permis vous avez vu de le
tourner dans ce sens là juste au coin
café une relève d'une relation naturelle
et du coup ça me bloque un peu est-ce
que ça me fait quelque chose
d'intéressant je suis pas sûr sûr mais
comme ben c'est pareil je sais pas si la
pyrogravure l'a2 au dessus des anneaux
est ce que c'est juste pour faire un
petit truc un peu comme ça rigolo ou est
ce que c'est un indice pour quelque
chose
mais redoutant dans d'autres centres
et ça aussi ça ça c'est terrible ça est
ce que c'est une vraie piste ou est ce
que c'est une fausse piste dire que
maintenant que je me dis que c'est un
peu comme une clé et qu'il faudrait que
je l'enfoncent ici en dessous il
faudrait que cette clé elles sortent par
là mais si elles se trouvent rien à voir
et c'est juste un truc pour me rendre où
froid serait peut-être que je laissais
comme ça je requiers faire un tour
complet ceux ci se trouvent ses fans
espèrent parfait et qu'il ya un moment
où il est un peu plus vite
et qui peut passer quoi
la page
ça n'a pas l'air très trop bon marché
à
la base il fait bugger ce casse tête bon
déjà c'est une difficulté intermédiaire
je regarderai d'alleurs exactement le
niveau je ne pense et un truc c'est une
smiley boxe boxe donc boîte donc il ya
ouverture
je vais aussi l'attaqué un peu ce côté
là parce que je suis en train de faire
le truc d'einstein match c'est de
répéter la même chose en attendant
résultats différents en même temps bon
bah désolé tu vas faire une accélération
mais je vais essayer de bien des vices
et ses trucs pour voir si on a un qui se
dévissent ou pas pire tu fais une coupe
des coupes davis je fais l'humour que je
peux en vidéo c'est pas tes pas ma
spécialité d'une mort en vidéo on va pas
se mentir
[Musique]
je peux le faire tenir debout et c'est
par les délices ans mais j'ai juste y
tiennent debout est-ce que et il est
presque en dessous la vie passe en
dessous du coup
c'est le tchèque en bois et pam à la
bestialité d'humour en vidéo on va pas
se mentir
non mais attendez vous suivent inquiète
vous avez vu déjà j'ai repositionné mais
ma colère
[Rires]
il est il est passé
au
déclic qui vient mais c'est quoi ce
délire chaque fois que tu viens je note
le truc non mais c'est incroyable c'est
arrivé dans combien de vidéos ça
ma technique était bonne et là d'un coup
bas ça s'est passé par en dessous la
plaque de métal mais oui mais c'est
beaucoup trop bizarre et donc ma théorie
c'est que maintenant il file en font
c'est de ce côté là mais c'est bizarre
mais il ya un truc nord c'est chelou
est-ce que tu as un nouveau message pour
moi loïc un nouveau message j'ai juste
du coup je suis jamais sûr de ce que je
viens de faire
parce que là il passe pas comme ça vous
voyez il est bloqué donc la salle à
passer un tout petit peu en dessous
petit à petit a quand j'y suis allé
doucement et booth est sorti là d'un
coup bon on va tenter l'ouverture mais
juste avant je vous ai pas oubliés je
vous en dis un tout petit peu plus sur
le sponsor du jour et l'intelligence
artificielle donc c'est un cours en
ligne qui s'appelle objectif il ya donc
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur
l'intelligence artificielle je vous
invite à faire ce cours en ligne
objectif il ya plein d'experts dont le
responsable de la recherche en
intelligence artificielle sur facebook
qui vous apprennent de manière simple et
ludique tous les enjeux à venir sur
l'intelligence artificielle le cours est
complètement gratuit ça prend environ 3
4 heures petite anecdote l'impact j'ai
fait le court en entier alors que
c'était pas sûr qu'on travaille ensemble
mais je les fais vraiment ça me plaisait
et puis j'aime bien quand j'ai un
diplôme à la fin et il est vraiment très
intéressant avec des vidéos des
questionnaires d être plus qu'à plein
d'autres gens que vous connaissez
d'ailleurs que l'expert facebook très
intéressant donc c'est complètement
gratuit aucun prérequis de nécessaire et
à la fin il ya un diplôme aussi qui vous
et romy si vous le souhaitez diplômes de
fin de formation qui peut même valoriser
votre cv suivant le domaine dans lequel
vous voulez travailler quand même et si
vous voulez lancer cette formation
rendez-vous dans le lien qui est dans
notre description n'ont pas besoin
d'intelligence artificielle pour se dire
ça ça va bien quand même de ce côté là
on se le test
il se passe un truc plus passe rien
attends je peux à si je peux appuyer
j'ai un peu de retenue comme un ressort
si je tourne en même temps merde c'est
pas si c'est ça ah si oui ah oui là
c'est bien enfoncer la main tant il se
passe quoi la plus continuer d'ouvrer
emploi mais n'ont pas encore atteint il
s'est passé un truc n'est pas
complètement
sinon faudrait que loïc revienne pour
que comme à chaque fois ça me porte
chance à allier
rina
[Musique]
je comprenais pas ce qui se passe en
termes de sensations ok donc ça en fait
quand j'ai appuyé s'appuie sur ses deux
bouts de bois ne faut pas déconner quand
même et du coup comme s'appuie là-dessus
il se désenclave de là en fait ça
s'était retenu que par le petit rebord
de sa vie après ça nous permet du coup
de reculer comme ça les deux vis
apparentes elle recule dans le guide et
après j'ai pu les sortir par leur
intermédiaire je suis d'accord parce que
c'est pas si compliqué que ça mais
[ __ ] faut être patient et puis il faut
croire en son hypothèse qu'aucun
maintenant je vais un casse tête bien
terminé c'est un fait avec ta maman haut
comme en aval à la chaîne de confiture
de ta mère
du coup là c'est bon à voilà ça bloque
ah ok ya une petite fragilité quand même
à faire attention pas trop de bourriner
quand même là quand on appuie et pas
hésité à le relever avec le doigt pour
que sar bloc là comme joker et pour
l'euro m besset très très simple parce
que on peut y aller avec le doigt titre
là on peut le passer et vous voyez comme
ça exactement comment je l'avais je
l'avais pas c'est tout à l'heure là il
est sous les deux rondelles de métal
qu'il fallait réussir à lever en même
temps et faire tout petit à petit vous
le remettez après au fond c'est la
serrure bloqués cast est résolu et comme
d'habitude si vous voulez ce que c'était
il ya deux solutions soit vous allez sur
mon instagram et je fais régulièrement
gagné les casse tête que j'ai réalisé en
vidéo donc n'hésitez pas à me suivre je
pense que je le mettrais aujourd'hui à
la diffusion sur la gagner et sinon si
vous le voulez vraiment pour vous d'une
manière sûre et certaine achetez-le dans
les boutiques pour française de
préférence il coûte une quarantaine
d'euros parce que c'est vraiment du
travail artisanal je vous mettrais un
lien de mire dans la description bientôt
je voulais spoil un peu mes seins
énorme casse-tête abonnez vous pour pas
rater ça activer la cloche activer vos
voisins qui vérifie si la vidéo est
sorti ou pas mais on l'a pas encore reçu
mais ça va être une dinguerie un casse
tête à plus de 20000 euros peut être à
plus de 25000 euros une pièce unique ça
va être une dinguerie merci encore à
l'institut montagnat open classe ronde
avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo depuis
qu'ils ont lancée objectif ia en 2020 il
ya 159 françaises et français qui ont
découvert l'intelligence artificielle
pour les rejoindre vous cliquez dans le
bien que dans la description prochaine
vidéo lundi je vous dis pas la
thématique mais ce sera à 18h et que
vous allez kiffer ça ici je vous mets
les deux derniers casse tête qui sont
parus sur la chaîne sur la chaîne ça se
voit que j'avais pas dormir prenez soin
de vous à très bientôt ciao siècle et
loïc un os